[Music]
with no end in sight to the political
turmoil over brexit
the people have taken to the streets in
recent weeks
in significant numbers pro and anti-eu
protests have remained largely peaceful
but passions are running high
police chiefs are warning all those who
have a platform to speak
to be measured in what they say in the
days ahead
their words could have consequences we
do think it's important
that people who have that access to the
public
do understand the impact of what they're
saying and what says and it's
particularly
because what they say may give
permission or
be perceived as giving permission to
other people and it may be some people
we know the boundaries
aren't quite the same as some of those
people in
public office there has been an
increasing number
of threats against members of parliament
police say they are now offering extra
security and advice
to mps who've asked for help on a daily
basis the protests
outside parliament here are normally
pretty small in nature and easily
manageable from a policing perspective
but the longer the arguments over brexit
continue
the greater the likelihood of more
significant demonstrations
and more angry voices
[Music]
across the country police forces have
stepped up public order training
there are now some 10 000 specially
trained officers nationally
available within 24 hours to be deployed
anywhere in the country
but such an intensive policing
commitment would struggle to be
maintained
beyond seven days without impacting on
other core policing responsibilities
at a time when forces are already
struggling to meet the demands
of day-to-day requirements a ban on
leave
and calls on the military for help as
happened after the terror attacks in
2017
might all be required they could carry
out
duties that may normally be carried out
by the police
let's say area security duties guarding
buildings things like that
roles that the army could do in the
background
in order to free up more police officers
to carry out public order duties
in the event of a problem police chiefs
say they have no intelligence of any
planning for public disorder in the days
ahead
but with recent protests on the rail and
road networks
along with an increasing number of
threats to mps
they remain on high alert and warned
they'll deal robustly
with those who break the law mark white
sky news